hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they
arrive in the next half hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
podcaster and journalist leslie riddick
and the conservative commentator tim
montgomery
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages now the mail dubs the
de-escalation of tensions between french
fishing boats and royal navy ships off
jersey
legrand surrender the metro describes
events in the channel with the headline
smash and crab while the sun says simply
take sprat the guardian reports on a
research study which concluded that the
government needs to spend over a hundred
billion pounds to rebuild the nhs
after the pandemic the financial times
leads with the bank of england's
forecast that 2021
will see the strongest economic growth
since the second world war
the telegraph reports that the prime
minister intends to go against the
advice of teaching unions
and overturn the rule that pupils must
wear masks in classrooms
and the eye reports on travel firms
offering reduced-priced covered testing
kits
in the hope of making foreign holidays
easier
and we're joined tonight by leslie
riddick and tim montgomery good evening
to both of you we're going to kick off
as the polls have now closed
counting is underway with the metro
and its coverage of the elections get
set for fallout friday and i'm gonna
have to try
really hard to say this properly so who
will get a kick in
the ballots uh who's it gonna be tim
well um we're looking at the papers
tonight of course uh
sarah as we do it traditionally on at
this time
on sky but probably the most interesting
thing we could be doing at the moment is
following the twitter accounts of beth
rigby and sam coats the
sky political team because they're
giving us the early indication of
what the parties internally think the
results might be
now the results are going to be spread
over three days and the first result i
think is going to be the heart and pool
by-election which of course
labour desperately wanted to hold but
looking
um from what sam and beth are tweeting
labour expecting very difficult night
particularly in the northeast
not only does it look like they might
lose hartlepool
wants a stronghold seat for them but
they could lose durham
and sunderland councils as well so
this is supposedly uh kierstarma's first
big
attempt to claw back the tory wins in
the so-called red wall seats
but it doesn't look like if these
indications are
true that it's going to be a very good
night for the labour leader
and i suppose there will then of course
be the focus on scotland that is
probably
the other big story of these elections
and the big question which uh
leslie may be a better place to answer
does nicola sturgeon get the majority
she hopes for
so that she can press boris to have the
uh
independence referendum yeah nicolas
sturgeon photographed
on page three of the metro which has all
of the various
leaders going out to cast their
votes and to get others to
cast their votes as well and leslie
scotland very significant in terms of
the constitution what it means for the
rest of the united kingdom
well yes and very striking how really um
if england is becoming um you know
fairly consistently tory
um scotland is becoming by the looks of
it
um very solidly snp i know everybody
kind of cringes with horror at having
any explanation of scotland's voting
system
but it's actually some
first-past-the-post seats and then a
second
list system that that tries to rectify
the imbalances created by
by the the first pass the post so it
looks as if the snp
will will win almost all their seats in
that first past the post section
they need to get 65 overall and they'll
it looks like the latest polls are
suggesting they will get that
if they don't uh the greens uh look
likely
to have their best election and the
combination would certainly give it
pro-independence majority
so in that sense just to hand the bat
the ball back across the court
uh to montgomery might be best placed to
say
whether boris johnson is going to
actually face reality
and recognize that this constitutes a
mandate
you two don't need me tim
well leslie of course is right the it
may be a very good
24 hours for boris johnson celebrating
the discomfort of
labor and that will go on into the
weekend because we've already seen the
labour left potentially gunning for kia
stammer
but boris's big question will be if if
nicola sturgeon gets a majority there's
going to be huge pressure on him to
grant
the scottish people a second referendum
and then up until now he's resisted that
hugely
but the moral pressure will be huge and
you've already had people like john
major the former
conservative prime minister saying that
if nicola sturgeon
wins the majority then boris johnson
should grant
that referendum so it won't just be
pressure coming from the snp
it could be pressure coming from with
his own party to grant the scottish
people the second referendum
in just a few years yeah we're not going
to get scotland's result overnight but
we will get the hartley pool one
expected in the early hours
of the morning but but as uh you were
saying tim
beth rigby being told by her sources
that the tories are confident
they're on the ground that they've won
it and let's move on to the other main
story in the papers today
and jersey and the mail the headline
legrand surrender french fisherman
executing a familiar maneuver tim
yes and um it's been a ridiculous day in
many ways hasn't it with um
the french and the british all saber
rattling in different ways and
it's it's dangerous for everyone
involved really the male's
front page talks about the next thing
that the
french trawlerman trench trawlers could
do would be blockade
calais to stop british exports of all
kinds getting to
france and so we really do need some
cool heads
um in this dispute now it was
understandable that
the british sent a couple of uh frigates
to
uh jersey to try and avoid a blockade of
of jersey but overall we need some
cooler heads and at the moment they seem
to be in short supply let's hope the
uh agitation that we saw today was
partly due to electioneering and um
maybe people will cool down in the days
ahead i certainly hope so
yeah i mean the headline writers have
certainly been having some fun smash and
crab in the metro takes sprat is the
headline on the front
of the sun but some of the language
around this
at leslie talking about being close to
war a new battle of trafalgar boris
johnson's falklands moment
an invasion i mean it's not exactly been
cool heads
and a call for calm no it's not and
i mean it's it's it's well it's
predictable perhaps and it seems to be
part of a role
when you look at a couple of the papers
they've actually got this
they've got the bank of england's
prediction about growth in the economy
uh they've got the news that we'll come
on to about uh the green list opening up
and people having holidays
and it's all a sort of bish bash bush
you know we're on a roll
and it seems a very kind of pro boris
sort of
feel the whole thing and of course not a
coincidence that this all happens on
election day
but you know when you when you read into
some of the detail particularly with the
financial times it has a very sober
um analysis of the whole thing calling
for an end to
posturing um and and more pragmatism
you've you've got to see that i mean the
the jersey
fishermen themselves very calm people
who point out that they have
like many fishermen across the whole of
britain been pretty roundly stuffed by
the
brexit arrangements and deal that has
happened
and that they've really they're the ones
who've suffered for the for the first
six months
not the the french fishermen the french
of course being very prone to having
extraordinarily robust
demonstrations and as far as one can see
having practically no coverage in the
french press whatsoever of this because
this is not a big deal for them
tim can i ask you briefly about the
timing of this in terms of domestic
politics i mean
it played well didn't it for boris
johnson and emmanuel
macron domestically to be seen to be
playing tough
yes and of course we're looking it
through a british prison but
there are polls now suggesting that
emmanuel macron
if he was to go to the final stage of
the french presidential election against
marine le pen
the leader of the far right she could
actually win
and so there is a real need for
macron the french president to also show
that he's sticking up for
french interest so yes we can look at
boris's motivations but
there are political factors at play in
france very much too
okay leslie tim for now thank you very
much we're going to take a short break
but coming up
boris johnson looks set to overall
teaching union's advice on masks in
classrooms we'll be discussing that next
i think it was the right decision for
facebook to take donald trump off the
platform
in fact i think they took this action
way too late
donald trump was was a serial spreader
of hate lies and violence over facebook
and
other social media platforms he
regularly violated facebook's community
guidelines
he was given a pass time and again
because he was the president of the
united states
and finally on january 7th he was
temporarily suspended from facebook
the oversight board yesterday upheld
that suspension
but kicked the ultimate decision about
whether the ban should be permanent
back to facebook itself i wish they
would have just
taken them down once and for all now's
the time
but here we are the oversight board
said that facebook had shirked its
responsibility
when it refused to just ban trump itself
kicking it over to this board with a set
of
fairly illusory powers um
so you know i believe that facebook
shouldn't have
platformed trump long long ago it's made
exception after exception
and we know that powerful leaders like
donald trump
bolsonaro modi have used facebook
to exploit and abuse their citizenry
it's important that facebook takes a
stand here
and ensures that world leaders cannot
use its platform
for authoritarianism and
to to abuse their citizens
so donald trump still has freedom of
speech
he started his own website this week
he's
you know put out a statement that has
gotten a ton of press attention he
is welcome to start his own website
welcome to start his own
social media platform but he does not
have
um the power to have reach on a platform
um that he uses for violence for abuse
to spread racism to spread lies about
the pandemic and the vaccine
and so forth he doesn't have that right
that's a privilege
hello my name is ina braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wave power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
[Music]
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
having to be afraid of drowning in my
own bedroom
and sometimes waking up in the middle of
the night with flood water in my room
we needed an organization that
specifically talked about the climate
and so me and my friends we
decided to put up youth advocates for
climate action philippines i had to join
the fight
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now leslie riddick and
tim
montgomery we're going to turn to the
front of the daily telegraph
uh it has a story that uh masks for
children in classrooms
will be coming to an end leslie
yes it's interesting they're forecasting
that on monday
uh boris johnson will uh change the
guidance for england
and um advise that that the masks no
longer need to be
worn from the 17th of may by secondary
school
pupils um and there's quite a lot in the
article
of kind of criticism of the national
education union
and quotes from some of its members
saying they feel that continuing to wear
the mask masks
is crazy when the the it'll be possible
for those same people
to be mixing indoors from that date with
uh other people
without wearing masks however um there's
there was a couple of days
ago um a big letter that was signed by
scientists
by five trade unions by public health
england experts
by parents by independent sage all
calling for masks to stay partly because
there's been a we rise
in uh covert infections since schools
went back
but mostly because there's no plans to
lift mass restrict
restrictions in places like public
transport um
or in shops where people spend less time
together so
there's other points you could make with
this but clearly that's not the point
that's being made
there's a big push here for boris to
take on the unions
and it feels like a very political
politically driven
article and and and move by by boris
johnson if it comes off
uh may the 17th tim also the date when
travel will
start to cautiously open up again
the eye says cheap tests will be offered
for british travelers the costs of pcr
tests have been seen of one of the big
deterrents for getting the travel
industry going again
yeah some of the costs that uh families
have had to pay for
a test coming in to the uk or leaving
have been extraordinary
really making the possibility of a
family holiday
or you know of course lots of people use
travel to go
and meet their their families lots of
british families have families abroad so
it's not just question of holiday it's
about keeping in touch with your
loved ones and so the costs of these uh
covet tests have been
prohibitive and so that's the good news
and in another paper the telegraph
though
it talks about some of the flight prices
the countries like portugal which may be
one of the favored countries in the new
regime doubling
so you gain on their swings and lose on
the roundabout really and with these um
changes in the cost of covid if you like
yeah as you say those flight prices
taking off with speculation that we're
gonna get
that green list within uh the coming
days
uh tim leslie for now thanks very much
indeed for taking us through the front
pages